Hadron Collider they say that that's the
day got shifted cause earthquakes
by sending plasma from Switzerland Italy
at high speeds opening portals into hell
or other dimensions and Shifting the
world into an alternate timeline in 2015
Cerny even admitted it attempted to
create tiny black holes so scientists
can study antimatter CERN insists it's
research including that of microscopic
black holes is perfectly safe but some
theorists believe it could cause a
collapse of the entire universe
so one word is like it's safe and one
person
in the universe you were sitting here
we're sitting here
[Laughter]
is what we're doing